so
my whole villain is this hyperactive
hive mind workflow
the tool is fine i don't want the tool
to go away but i want to replace the
hyperactive my workflow i think this is
going to be
one of the biggest value generating
productivity revolutions
of the 21st century i quote an anonymous
ceo is pretty well known who says this
is going to be the moonshot
of the 21st century is going to be of
that importance there's so much latent
productivity
that's being suppressed because we just
figure things out on the fly in email
that as we figure that out i think it's
going to be
hundreds of billions of dollars you're
so
absolutely right the question is
what does the world without email look
like how do we fix email
so what happens is at least in my vision
you identify well actually there's these
different processes that make up my work
day
like these are things that i do
repeatedly often in collaboration with
other people that do useful things for
my
company or whatever right now most of
these processes are implicitly
implemented with a hyperactive hive mind
how do we do this thing like answering
client questions to shoot messages back
and forth you know how do we do this
thing
posting podcast episodes we'll just
figure it out on the fly my main
argument is we actually have to do like
they did in the industrial sector
take each of these processes and say is
there a better way to do this
and by better i mean a way that's going
to minimize the need to have unscheduled
back and forth messaging
so we actually have to do process
engineering this created a
massive growth in productivity in the
industrial sector during the 20th
century we have to do it in knowledge
work we can't just rock and roll in
inboxes we actually have to say
how do we deal with client questions
well let's put in place a process that
doesn't require us to
send messages back and forth how do we
post podcast episodes let's automate
this to a degree where
i don't have to just send you a message
on the fly and you do this
process by process and the pressure on
that inbox is released and now you don't
have to check it every six minutes so
you still have email i mean like i need
to send you a file sure i'll use email
but we're not coordinating or
collaborating over email or slack which
is just a faster way of doing the hive
mind i mean
the slack doesn't solve anything there
you have
better structured bespoke processes i
think that's what's going to unleash
this massive productivity bespoke so the
interesting thing is like
for example you and i exchanged some
emails so obviously i
uh for let's just say my particular case
i schedule podcasts there's a bunch of
different tasks
fascinatingly enough that i do that
could be converted into processes
yeah is it up to me to create that
process or do you think we also need to
build
tools just like email was a protocol for
uh helping us create proxy for the
different
tasks i mean i think ultimately the
whole organization the whole team has to
be involved i think ultimately
there's certainly a lot of investor
money being spent right now to try to
figure out those tools
right so i think silicon valley has
figured this out in the past couple of
years this is the difference between
when i was talking to people after deep
work
uh and now five years later is this
scent is in the air
right because there's so much latent
productivity so yes there are going to
be new tools which i think could help
they're already
tools that exist i mean in the different
groups i profiled use things like trello
or basecamp or
asana or flow and you know our schedule
wants an acuity like there's
a lot of tools out there the key is not
to think about it in terms of
what tool do i replace email with
instead you think about it with
i have a pro we're trying to come with a
process that reduces back and forth
messages oh what tool might help us
might help us do that yeah and i would
push it's not about necessarily
efficiency
in fact some of these things are going
to take more time so writing a
letter to someone is like a high value
activity is probably worth doing
the thing that's killer is the back and
forth because now i have to keep
checking right so we scheduled this
together because i knew you from before
but like most of the
the interviews i was scheduling for this
actually i have a
process with my publicist where we use a
shared document and she puts stuff in
there and then i check it twice a week
and there's scheduling options and i say
here's what i want to do this one or
this will work for this one or whatever
and it takes more time in the moment
than just but it means that we have
almost no back and forth messaging
for podcast scheduling which without
this so like with my uk publisher
i didn't put this process into place
because we're not doing as many
interviews
but it's all the time and i'm like oh
man i can really feel the difference
right it's the back and forth that's
killer
i suppose it is up to the individual
people involved like you said
uh uh knowledge workers like they have
to carry the responsibility
of uh creating processes like how
always asking the first principles
question how can this be converted into
a process
yeah so you can start by doing this
yourself like just with what you can
control
i think ultimately once the team teams
are doing that i think that's probably
the right scale
if you try to do this at the
organizational scale you're going to get
bureaucracy right
so if it's you know right all right if
if elon musk is going to
dictate down to everyone at tesla or
something like this
that's too much remove you get
bureaucracy but if it's we're a team of
six that's working together
on you know whatever powertrain software
then we can figure out on our own what
are our processes how do we want to do
this so it's ultimately also creating a
culture we're saying like
in email sending an email just for the
hell of it it should be taboo like yeah
so like you are being uh
you're being destructive to the
productivity of the team by sending this
email
yes as opposed to uh helping develop
a process and so on uh that
that will ultimately automate this
that's why i'm trying to spread this
message of the
context switches it's poison i get so
much into the science of it i think we
underestimate
how much it kills us they have to wrench
away our context look at a message and
come back
and so once you have the mindset of it's
a huge thing to ask of someone
to have to take their attention off
something and look back at this and if
they have to do that for
three or four times like we're just
going to figure this out on the fly and
every message is going to require five
checks of the inbox while you wait for
it well
now you've created whatever it is at
this point 25 or 30
contact shifts like you've just done a
huge disservice to someone say this
would be like if i had a professional
athlete it's like hey do me a favor
i need to go do this press interview but
to get there you're going to have to
carry this sandbag
and sprint up this hill like completely
exhaust your muscles and then you have
to go play a game like of course i'm not
going to ask an athlete to do
like an incredibly physically demanding
thing right before a game
but something as easy as thoughts
question mark
or like hey do you want to jump on a
call and it's going to be six back and
forth messages to figure it out
it's kind of the cognitive equivalent
right you're taking the wind out of
someone
yeah and by the way for people who are
listening because i
recently posted a few job openings for
so on to help with this thing
and one of the things that people are
surprised when they work with me is how
many spreadsheets and processes are
involved
yeah it's like claude shannon right i
talked about communication theory or
information theory
it takes time to come up with a clever
code up front so you spend more time up
front figuring out those spreadsheets
and trying to
get people on board with it but then
your communication going forward is all
much more efficient so over time
you're using much less bandwidth right
so you you do pain up front
yes it's quicker just right now to send
an email but if i spend a half day to do
this over the next six months
i've saved myself 600 emails
you